you're watching the free pilot training
channel and this is private pilot ground
lesson 22
and on today's episode we're going to be
discussing all the other airspace you
need to know as a private pilot
but don't skip this lesson because this
information is really popular
with dpes when they're giving their oral
exam questions
a lot of times if you know this
information they'll leave you alone on
some of the other
airspace questions speaking of that i
created a separate playlist specifically
for all the airspace study material
i'll throw that here in case you want to
start at the beginning and work your way
to this lesson
when we talk about other airspace
there's a lot of different airspace that
falls into this category
but for today i want to focus on what
you need to know as a private pilot
don't be intimidated by all this stuff
it's really not that complicated and i'm
going to tell you exactly what you need
to know
the first example of this airspace is
the local airport advisory
this is an area where you can get
weather advisory service from a flight
service station on certain airports in
alaska
because these areas are only found in
alaska i'm not going to go into any more
detail
but if you need more information check
out the aim now let's talk about
military training routes
this is some airspace you definitely
want to be aware of and that's because
military aircraft can be maneuvering at
high
speeds along these routes in fact
they're allowed to fly
over 250 knots when they're using these
routes to find these first look for
these gray lines
now notice that these roots are labeled
with a vr or ir
followed by three or four digit number
vr
stands for visual route that means these
routes could be occupied when there's
vfr weather
then if you see these ir routes those
are instrument routes and those can be
operated
in any weather when you see these routes
with a four digit number that means
they're operated at 1500 feet agl
and below but if you see these roots
labeled with three numbers like this one
that means they can be operated above or
below 1500 feet agl
if you need to find out if these
military training routes are active the
best way to do this is to contact the
nearest flight service station
in this case it's jonesboro radio and we
can either call them on the phone or we
can use this frequency right here while
we're in flight
and just ignore this higher frequency
right here that's a military uhf
frequency
and here's a little g whiz information
there's actually one more
sr routes or slow routes are uncharted
military training routes
and that's because they're typically
operated below 250 knots
next we're going to talk about temporary
flight restrictions or tfrs
these areas are exactly what they sound
like when these are active
pilots are not allowed to fly into these
temporarily here's a few examples of the
many reasons why you might see a tfr
these can exist to protect people or
property in the air or on the ground
protect the president vice president or
other public figures
and in some cases these may prevent an
unsafe congestion of sightseeing
aircraft
above an incident or event that may
generate a high degree of public
interest
for example you might find one of these
over the stadium of your favorite
football team
and i guarantee you you're not the only
one who'd like to see him score that
winning touchdown from the air
okay so now how do i know when these are
active and where to find them
first you can check the faa's website
specifically made for tfrs
then you can either search for the
center airspace you're going to be
flying through or you can click here on
the tfr
map then you can zoom in on any
applicable tfrs and take a look down at
the nodes
you can also get these if you use flight
planning aids like 1-800 weather brief
for flight and other flight planning
software sometimes you'll find that tfrs
reoccur regularly
you can find these by these magenta
diamonds on the vfr
sectional then to find out if these are
active you can check the nodums or the
same places we just talked about
now let's take a quick look at parachute
jump areas while it's pretty obvious
what
these areas are for what may not be
obvious is how to find these areas and
whether or not they're active
that's really important information to
know because you don't want to fly
through one of these areas when these
people are jumping
the first place we can find this
information is in the chart supplement
there's actually a section specifically
for parachute jumping areas
the first thing you'll notice here is
that they separate these by states
then they give you an approximate
location a maximum drop altitude
and just some remarks on when they're
going to be operating when these areas
are used fairly regularly you'll
sometimes see these on the vfr sectional
the parachute jump areas can still exist
when they're not noted
in the chart supplement or on the vfr
sectional and the best place to look for
these
is in the nodums now let's take a look
at published vfr routes
here are a few examples of these but
basically these routes are designed so
that vfr traffic
can transition easily through complex
airspace
vfr flyways are nothing more than
recommended flight paths so that vfr
pilots
can avoid major controlled traffic flows
you'll find these depicted as the big
blue markings on the back of the class
bravo airspace terminal area charts
now while you don't need a specific
clearance to fly on these routes it is
your responsibility to make sure you
follow all the other rules before going
into any other types of airspace
some class bravo airspace have something
called vfr corridors
these are essentially vfr tunnels that
extend to the class bravo airspace
these dash magenta lines are an example
of a vfr corridor going through san
diego's airspace
and you just want to make sure you read
all these rules before you use one of
these
as you can see you don't need a
clearance to go into this particular
corridor
but it'd be really easy to bust the
class bravo airspace which could get you
violated
then we have class bravo airspace vfr
transition routes
these are denoted by these double-headed
magenta arrows
basically this is the preferred routing
atc wants you to take
if you're going to be transitioning the
class bravo airspace the big thing for
you to remember is that you're actually
going into the class bravo airspace to
travel on these routes
so remember you must be cleared to enter
and now for one of the most common
questions on the oral exam
wet airspace is denoted by this gray
ring surrounding this airport
if you said terminal radar service area
or tursa you're absolutely correct
most terses surround medium-sized
towered airfields with class delta
airspace
and while you're not required to call
approach and get radar services
it can be very beneficial because this
airspace can sometimes get kind of busy
and now we have national security areas
you can identify these by these heavy
dash magenta lines
as you can tell from this note pilots
are requested to avoid flight into these
areas
so i guess you could say these are kind
of voluntary usually
now these could be activated by nodum
and then they could become a prohibited
area
so i guess the moral of the story is
check the notems if you think you might
want to fly through one of these
next let's take a quick look at the air
defense identification zone
this is airspace that the federal
government has decided that in the
interest of national security
they need to readily identify locate and
control all
aircraft coming in and out of this space
you can find this airspace in a few
different areas including 12 nautical
miles off the coast of the united states
and on the border of mexico
if you're thinking you want to take a
vacation down into mexico make sure you
have a mozi transponder a working
two-way radio and you'll have to file a
flight plan
in addition to that there are a couple
more things you have to do in order to
cross into the aidets
so make sure you check out the aim if
you want to do that next we have the
flight restricted zone
now i'm not going to get into a ton of
detail on this one because if you want
to fly within 60 nautical miles of
washington
airport you have to do a special
awareness training anyways
if you need to take that training you
can find it on the faa safety website
now once we get within 30 nautical miles
we have this cascaded ring
inside of here we have what's called the
special flight rules area
this airspace starts at the surface and
goes up to but does not include
1 8 000 msl now if you think you want to
go in here in addition
to that training i just mentioned
there's a couple things you'll need
first you have to establish two-way
radio communications
now if you're going into the class bravo
airspace you'll have to get that
clearance separately
then you'll need a mode c transponder
with an assigned squawk code
last but not least you have to be on a
special flight rules area
or an ifr flight plan as we get closer
to the center of the special flight
rules area
you'll notice another area with a 15
nautical mile radius
this is called the flight restricted
zone or
frz for short if for some crazy reason
you want to go inside the frz
there's a couple special tsa
requirements you have to meet first you
have to get a personal identification
number or pin
then you also have to have a background
check when it comes to the aidets the
special flight rules area
and the frz these are all locations
where you don't want to fly into those
without following the rules
if you do you run the risk of being
intercepted by military aircraft
in worst case scenario they could
potentially shoot you down
because of this you really want to know
your stuff before going into one of
these areas
now if you ever see these areas with a
blue border with the dots inside
these can be a couple different things
when they're on land these can either be
wildlife areas wilderness areas or
national parks
and guess what it says right beside them
what they are this one happens to be a
wilderness area
for these areas pilots are requested to
operate above 2000 feet agl
now while it seems like these are
voluntary i recommend abiding by these
altitudes
if you hit a bald eagle while buzzing
the treetops in one of these areas
that one's going to be kind of hard to
explain that being said if you ever run
into these noaa marine areas
you're required to operate above 2000
feet agl
and these are marked the same exact way
the last type of other airspace we'll
talk about today are areas where there
are tethered balloons
check out this restricted area right
here as you can see from this note we've
got an unmarked balloon on a cable that
extends up to 1 5000
msl now we could flip our sectional over
to the back to get some more information
but this tells me everything i need to
know right there
if your plane hits that cable it could
potentially rip it right in half
and most pilots have a little bit of
trouble trying to fly two planes at one
time
i hope you enjoyed this episode of the
free pilot training channel
if you did please hit that like button
for me before you check out what other
great videos i have that can help you
become a better pilot
and i'll see you in the next video